inzwischen ist man ja schon wirklich
ziemlich abgehärtet als Bürger und
newskonsument nach all den schlechten
Nachrichten aber irgendwann ist es dann
auch mal gut wie viel Tiefschläge denn
noch jetzt kackt Deutschland auch noch
ab bei der neuen Pisastudie ah peinlich
oder ja dabei ist Bildung doch unser
einziger Rohstoff heißt es immer die
bundesweiten Leistung in Mathe
Naturwissenschaften und Lesekompetenz
sind so schlecht wie noch nie über 20
Jahre
nach dem ersten schockierenden pisock
sie erinnern sich ist man geschockter
denn je nie waren deutsche Schüler in
lesen und Mathe schlechter als jetzt die
erreichten Punkte in Mathe so wenig wie
nie zuvor besonders in Mathematik gibt
es Nachholbedarf in Bereich Mathematik
in Mathematik vor allem in Mathematik
und vor allem in Mathematik ein und ein
ist ein und
nicht ist wirklich bedrückend meine
Damen und Herren 30% der deutschen
15-Jährigen können nicht richtig rechnen
das sind mehr als die
Hälfte die Ursachen sind komplex aber
natürlich waren die Schulschließung
während Corona ein Fehler und man hat
viel zu wenig gemacht um deren Folgen
aufzufangen es braucht dringend mehr
Personal vor allem für sogenannte
Brennpunktschulen ja wir verschenken das
Potenzial von Generationen meine Damen
und Herren und nach wie vor die
Abhängigkeit der schulischen Leistung
vom Einkommen der Eltern in kaum einem
OECD Land höher als bei uns beschämend
und jetzt wir haben jetzt so eine
Situation wo man weiß die Bundeswehr
muss anders ausgestattet werden ich
wünschte mir eine Situation wo man weiß
die Schulen müssen anders ausgestattet
werden Bildung muss anders ausgestattet
werden also da bräuchten wir eigentlich
so ein wie war das
doppelwums verstehe dann muss also nur
noch Putin eine deutsche Schule
angreifen
andererseits so eine Berliner
Gesamtschule ist manchmal besser
bewaffnet als die
Bundeswehr
so tatsache ist allerdings es gibt gar
keinen Grund als Erwachsene Regierung
auf Schülerinnen und Schüler
runterzugucken die Ampel ist doch selber
versetzungsgefährdet und ihr
Nachtragshaushalt für 2023 laut
Bundesrechnungshof vielleicht auch schon
wieder
verfassungswidrig der deutsche
Lehrerverband warnt unsere Schüler
werden immer schwächer in Mathe lesen
und Naturwissenschaften die Folgen sind
verherend wie diese Berliner
nachhilfegruppe beweist die seit zwei
Jahren vergeblich versucht gemeinsam zu
regieren Christian schafft es einfach
nicht einen verfassungskonformen
Haushalt vorzulegen die Ursachen liegen
schon in der Grundschulzeit als
Grundschüler habe ich Mickey Maus
gelesen und Autobild Olaf ist zwar
Klassensprecher seine mündlichen
Leistungen bleiben aber katastrophal er
hier weiß nicht was eine Insolvenz ist
Karl wiederum scheitert an einer
einfachen krankenhausreform und Klara
wollte 400000 Wohnungen im Jahr bauen
schafft im Werkunterricht aber nicht mal
ein Vogelhäuschen deshalb endlich mehr
Geld für Bildung jeder Cent
hilft so sieht
aus und von wegen die 20er das jahrzehn
der Bildungschancen schön
W aus Textaufgabe drei Koalitionspartner
haben 60 Milliarden Äpfel für einen
großen Apfelkuchen eingeplant aber dann
urteilt Karlsruhe die Äpfel haben ihn in
Wirklichkeit nie gehört Frage welcher
der drei apfelfreunde hat am wenigsten
in der
Birne ich weiß es nicht ja heute feiert
die ampelregierung ihren zweiten
Geburtstag ja gut mir kommt's viel
länger vor muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen
denen wahrscheinlich auch der Haushalt
24 kann nun doch nicht mehr vor
Weihnachten im Bundestag beschlossen
werden sie verhandeln weiter auch heute
falls da völlig überraschend noch
irgendwas rauskommt weiß ich das zum
Zeitpunkt dieser Aufzeichnung nicht aber
ich sag mal so selbst wenn das
kümmerliche restvertrauen in die
Regierung ist sowieso weg und ich hatte
mich so verlassen auf die Vorhersage
dieser sehr schlechten Wahrsagerin ich
bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wie in der
Vergangenheit auch in der Koalition es
möglich sein wird dass alle aufeinander
zugehen und dass wir zu einer guten
Lösung
kommen welcher Vergangenheit hat die
denn gelebt aufeinander zugehen in der
Ampel klar zugegeben es gab auch einige
Krisen für die sie nichts können aber
die Haushaltskrise die wir gerade
erleben ist komplett hausgemacht als
wären Bürger und Wirtschaft nicht schon
genug verunsichert wie schwer kann es
denn bitte sein sich über poblige 17
Milliarden Euro zu einigen stattdessen
immer weiter zof mein Gott jetzt kommt
jetzt kommt im Januar der sogenannte
vorläufige Haushalt da wird nur noch das
Nötigste bezahlt und für jedes Extra
müssen die Minister dann bei Lindner
betteln Christian darf ich ein
hanuta vor dem Essen ja weltweit
beömmeln sich die Ökonomen über unsere
komischen Haushaltsregeln über Deutsche
die sich endgültig in die Rezession
sparen aus Prinzip wegen einer
herbeifantasierten Schuldenkrise hier
unsere Schuldenquote im G7 Vergleich
Deutschland ist übrigens der minibalken
ganz links im Bild wo ist das Problem
Freunde wo Schuldenbremse so
modifizieren dass echte
Zukunftsinvestitionen die seit Jahren
aufgeschoben werden ausgenommen sind und
gleichzeitig klimaschädliche
Subventionen streichen genau wie
Sozialleistung die auch bei Leuten
landen die sie gar nicht brauchen
Feierabend und ich sag mal so wer sich
nur gründlich genug umguckt entdeckt
überall Sparpotenzial Stichwort
Bürgergeld zumindest kurzfristig ist da
überhaupt kein Sparpotenzial sagt die
Bundesagentur Lindners nächstes
potenzielles Sparziel die
entwicklungshilfeministerin Svenja
Schulze und das finde ich erstmal
gut stimmt die könnte man vielleicht
einsparen ja wenn man es den
bürgergeldschnorr nicht wegnehmen darf
dann eben der Entwicklungshilfe in
dieser Ampel gibt wirklich keiner eine
gute Figur keiner auch nicht die
Kanzlerpartei SPD inzwischen abgestürzt
auf
14% wow ja zum ersten Mal sind die Sozen
nur noch viertstärkste Kraft heute
startet ihr Parteitag in Berlin laut
leidantrag will man da eine Art
klimasoli für Superreiche eine Reform
der erbschafts und Schenkungssteuer
Normalverdiener entlasten so linke
Sachen halt von denen alle wissen dass
sie eh nie kommen weder in einer Ampel
noch in der groco die Bananen hab mal
eine Frage ja wie zufrieden sind Sie mit
der SPD oh
ja wenn dir die Rentner von der Fahne
gehen dann gute
Nacht klar gehört dazu zur Fernis die
SPD hat den Mindestlohn durchgesetzt
und bestimmt auch andere gute Sachen
trotzdem fragen sich viele Bürger wofür
genau die Sozialdemokraten in der Ampel
eigentlich stehen das fragt sogar der
freche neue jusof was der sich traut
lieber Olaf falls Dich in Deiner
Burg in deinem Berliner Kanzleramt noch
irgendetwas erreicht falls du dich noch
daran erinnerst für welche Partei du
angetreten bist ändere deinen
Kurs Olaf in der
Burg
Alter fordert der vom Kanzler er soll
sich an was erinnern eine
Unverschämtheit ich glaube das wird ein
sehr lustiger Parteitag in den nächsten
Tagen und wie schade dass in dieser
historischen Krise von der Union von der
wichtigsten Opposition so wenig
konstruktives kommt Söder verkündet z.B
ein genderverbot in Bayern was enorm
weiterhilft und Friedrich märz ist
weiter sauer wegen der
bürgergelderhöhung ja also über die 12%
plus ja er ist sauer weil die Inflation
ja inzwischen niedriger ist sagt er
übrigens bei der letzten Harz 4 Erhöhung
gab's
0,6% mehr die Inflation lag da bei rund
5% aber das war natürlich total gerecht
will sagen hoffentlich bleiben uns
Neuwahlen erspart und damit dieses Duell
Schulz VSS MZ auf die Fresse fertig los
mit Boxpromoter gerno tasknecht in der
linken Ecke Olaf der drüge vom Deich
Scholz extürsteher bei der wburgbank er
schlägt so hart zu dass er danach selber
Gedächtnislücken hat
in der rechten Ecke Friedrich der Bomber
von Blackrock März der natürliche Feind
aller
bürgergeldempfänger es hilft ja nichtich
wir müssen halt mit den Kandidaten leben
die wir haben z.B einem Titelverteidiger
der weder Willens noch in der Lage ist
uns Bürgern seine Politik zu erklären
sag doch mal du großer Finanzexperte
jetzt wo der Letzte gemerkt hat dass du
gar kein Experte bist was wird denn nun
aus den ganzen Klimaprojekten ohne Geld
wir wollen uns dieser Aufgabe stellen
und werden das auch hinbekommen dass wir
genau diese Zukunftsinvestitionen auch
hinbekommen werden wir werden es
hinbekommen dass wir es hinbekommen
werden nach dem Satz sind bei der
Gesellschaft für deutsche Sprache
mehrere Menschen schreiend aus dem
Fenster gesprungen mein Gott ein
einziger gerader Satz muss doch mal drin
sein und sei es nur wenn der blöde
Weihnachtsbaum vor der kanzlerhütte
aufgestellt wird irgendein normaler Satz
kaum ein
anderes etwas anderes ist so sehr mit
Deutschland verbunden wie die
Vorstellung vom Wald und deshalb finde
ich ist es gut dass wir daran heute auch
erinnern
können die Vorstellung vom Wald sag doch
einfach schöner Baum froh
Weihnachten und dann der Herausforderer
Friedrich März
1,98 soziale Kälte da tut sich ein
Milliardenloch auf und Fritzes erster
Reflex ist das Geld holen wir uns von
den schwchsten wir halten es für falsch
dass das Bürgergeld jetzt zum 1 Januar
2024 noch einmal um 12% angehoben
wird genau 61 € mehr für die Faulen das
wäre ja Umverteilung von oben nach
unten andersrum findet er umverteilen
übrigens völlig in Ordnung beim
Dienstwagenprivileg zum BEP wieso
bringen die heiligen drei Könige Maria
und Josef eigentlich Geschenke das sind
doch Obdachlose ich wünsche allen einen
guten schönen ersten Advent und eine
schöne Vorweihnachtszeit so kann es
bleiben ist es wunderbar hier im
Sauerland ja dann bleib doch im
Sauerland das sind die zwischen denen
wir uns entscheiden sollen kann doch
wohl nicht wahr sein ich fordere ein
völlig neues Duell irgendeiner von den
letzten zwei drei linken bei der SPD
gegen irgendeinen sprechenden Stammtisch
von der Union mir völlig egal
welcher ich habe es vergessen ich bin
jetzt auf
tiktok ja von mir aus Markus ich bin
öfter bei tiktok als im Landtag Sch
g der linke lieber
[Musik]
Haken ger
hknecht wünscht sich ein anderes Duell
so me D und Herren und jetzt aber mal
ein ganz schlimmer Satz der leider
stimmt alles läuft für Vladimir Putin in
diesen Tagen ja es ist so der
ukrainekrieg hat sich als Stellungskrieg
festgefahren der Westen ist kriegsmüde
die Unterstützung für Kiev bröckelt
dafür ist Putin aber international total
geächtet keiner will mit dem Mann
gesehen werden also außer bei seinem
Besuch gerade in Abu Dhabi wo man ihn
mit Ehrengarde und Düsenjets begrüßt hat
und in Saudi-Arabien wo er seinen Bro
Prinz Salman ghettto Style begrüßt hat
grüß Dich Alter journalistenzersäger gut
siehst du aus hast du trainiert ja die
Botschaft dieser
kuscheltermine andere Länder überfallen
bringt vielleicht kurz Ärger aber am
Ende lohnt sich es doch Präsident Shi
bestellt bei Amazon schon die Gardinen
für seinen Zweitwohnsitz in Taiwan das P
in der Ukraine spielt Putin sauber in
die Hände wegen seiner Überlegenheit in
Sachen Menschen und Material der hat so
gute Laune der spricht jetzt offiziell
von Krieg ist ihn das aufgefallen er
nennt es jetzt krieg und nicht mehr
spezialoperation zur Friedenssicherung
ja so ist das bis neulich auch auch
viele deutsche sagen in diesen Tagen
komm lasst uns den Konflikt doch
einfrieren wegtuppern damit Ruhe ist
eventuell ein Denkfehler wie Putins
aktuelle Drohung an das natom Mitglied
Lettland beweist die Letten wagen es
doch tatsächlich von russischen
Mitbürgern Sprachtest zu verlangen ich
glaube nicht dass das Glück in die
Häuser derjenigen kommt die so eine
Politik
verfolgen Nein zu denen kommt der
Vladimir in die Häuser ja ein Fünftel
der Ukraine ist Krim mitgerechnet immer
noch in russischer Hand klar wäre er da
mit Konflikt einfrieren einverstanden
logisch hier Putin in
Vorweihnachtsstimmung in Russland müssen
Sie wissen hängt man seine Wunschzettel
nämlich an den Baum warte mal was steht
denn auf seinem Estland Lettland litunen
und
Sachsen eins davon wä für mich
okay ich sag aber nicht welches die
russische Kri läuft der weil auf
Hochtouren man schätzt Putin produziert
sieben Mal so viel Artilleriegeschosse
für den ukrainekrieg wie der komplette
Westen zusammengerechnet
75% der russischen Staatsausgaben gibt
er für Rüstung aus das ist Wahnsinn
Putin braucht den Krieg als Dauerzustand
auch innenpolitisch sein Regime wird ja
immer repressiver die Ukrainer kriegen
der weil vom Westen genug Waffen um
nicht zu verlieren fürs gewinnen reicht
es nicht und das ist wohl genauso
gewollt von jo Biden und Olaf Scholz ja
deswegen liefert Deutschland ja auch
keine taurusraketen an Kiev ja
das kann man so entscheiden muss man
aber nicht an Putins Entschlossenheit
besteht jedenfalls gar kein Zweifel der
hat sein Land komplett
durchmilitarisiert inklusive kinderarmee
sie hat bereits 1,3 Millionen Kinder und
Jugendliche
rekrutiert wohin richtest du denn deine
Waffe was habe ich gerade gesagt ich
mit angeblich spontanen Aktionen zeigen
Schulkinder dass sie für den russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
[Musik]
sind ja
faschistische faschistische Dreckskerle
übrigens das Jugendwort des Jahres in
Russland bei uns war es Gufi das war
auch schön fenappell für russische
Schüler ist inzwischen
pichtsams Reste von Demokratie so hat
Putin gerade erst die lgbtq Bewegung als
extremistische Organisation einges
gestuft wie den is es gab ratzien und
Verhaftung in Moskauer Schwulenclubs
ganz Russland soll im großen Ziel ja wie
sagt man das entquiert werden Beispiel
Matroschkas sind jetzt verboten weil
niemand in einem fremden Körper stecken
darf schon gar nicht Frauen in Frauen
wie ekelft ist das denn die
Transsibirische Eisenbahn enthält zu
viel Trans und heißt jetzt normative
sibirische Eisenbahn sämtliche Flüge von
Moskau nach Lesbos sind gestrichen
Putins Kampfjets müssen ab sofort jeden
Regenbogen beballern und aus allen
russisch brotpackungen müssen die
Buchstaben LGBT und q per Hand
aussortiert werden
natürlich
Kulturkampf und ich sage ih genau wegen
sind Teile der AFD nach wie vor große
Putin Fans im Grunde Russlands U-Boot im
Deutschen Bundestag diese Herren hier
empfinden jedenfalls nicht allzu viel
Empathie für die Ukraine vor allem nicht
für ukrainische Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland in ihrer Heimat können Sie
in weitesten Teilen friedlich leben auch
wir müssen den Ukrainern den Weg nach
Hause erleichtern indem wir ihn das
Bürgergeld
abstellen nur als Hilfestellung gedacht
er meint es n ja kupala auf einer Linie
mit den Republikanern in den USA die
weiter Hilfsgelder für die Ukraine
blockieren auch diese Woche Putin weiß
er muss einfach nur durchhalten bis zur
US-Wahl bis sein alter Kumpel Donald
Trump wieder ins Weiße Haus einzieht und
aus den USA dann endgültig eine
Autokratie macht ja und das weiß man
weil der Donald es ganz offen sagt wenn
ich gewinne werden meine Kritiker und
meine Gegner angeklagt und eingesperrt
aus Rache sagt er es soll Zwischenlager
für Massendeportationen geben und nicht
100% Trump loyale Beamte werden gefeuert
wird also eine sehr aufregende US-Wahl
nächstes Jahr aber wahrscheinlich ist es
ja dann auch die letzte ne so und wir
schalten mal live nach Guantanamo zur
deutschstämmigen Gisa Flake Chief Master
Sergeant der wachenmannschaft dort Frau
Flake oder
Flake sie bereiten sich schon vor auf
nächsten November yeah klar ein Glück
dass man das Lager hier nie dicht
gemacht hat ich habe immer gewusst dass
wir das eines Tages noch brauchen nur
dann eben für Amerikaner America
first ist ja auch ein Riesenvorteil dass
eine Diktatur mal angekündigt wird wie
oft ist man in der Geschichte schon
überrascht worden von sowas diesmal kann
keiner überrascht
tun wir versprechen Ihnen wir werden die
Kommunisten die Faschisten und das linke
ungezieefer
ausrotten
ausrotten Ungeziefer das bringt den
Präsidenten auf die Palme diese Sprache
habe man so beiden in den 30er Jahren in
Nazi Deutschland gehört ja und er muss
es ja wissen er war ja in den 30ern
schon dabei mit Anfang
40 sorry den muss ich machen natürlich
Trump hetzt gegen Einwanderer die aus
Gefängnissen und Irrenanstalten in die
USA kämen und das Zitat amerikanische
Blut vergiften das ist doch eins zu ein
faschistensprache ja
Entschuldigung seit wann darf man sich
keine Sorgen mehr um sein Blut machen
vor allem wenn man so kostbares Blut hat
wie
Trump
geru yeah great stuff geiles Zeug wollen
alle haben ja ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass euch da in good old
Germany gerade der Stift geht unter
Trump werden die USA rausgehen aus der
NATO und dann müsst ihr deutschen PLZ
selber bezahlen für eure Sicherheit oh
da guckt er traurig selber verteidigen
das kennt er nicht ne wie jetzt selber
ich verstehe gar nicht was Sie meinen ja
vergiss es seht ihr dann schon ich habe
hier ganz andere Sorgen wie kriegen wir
die unter die vielen neuen Kunden die
bald kommen ehemalige Trump Berater die
ihn heute kritisieren also Verräter alle
Demokraten Mexikaner die ganzen
Pornostars denen er Schweigegeld gezahlt
hat das das wird ein echtes Platzproblem
hier wenn der rechtsstat endlich
abgeschafft
ist das heißt wenn ich gewinne und
jemand greift mich an dann rufe ich den
Generalstaatsanwalt an und sage pass auf
klag den an auch wenn er nichts
verbrochen hat ich sage klag ih an wegen
irgendwas du wirst schon was
finden
eben und Sie müssen auch aufpassen welke
Trump hat mal das ist kein Witz das
Justizministerium aufgefordert gegen die
comedy show Saturday night live zu
ermitteln wegen der gemeinen Sketsche
über ihn und wie ist der Zufall will die
CIA hat mir heute eine Liste gemailt mit
allen Sendungen in den die heute show
was zu Trump gemacht hat
z.B am 27 januar 2017 direkt nach seiner
Vereidigung wirklich schlimme trumpwitze
am 3 Februar ebenso am 10 den ganzen
März durch und dann als Tiefpunkt
hier Orang wutan
really ja gut das ging aber damals vor
allem gegen die Affen
so du packst jetzt schon mal sicher dein
kulturbeutelchen Freundchen ja Frankfurt
Guantanamo das sind nur 11 Stunden Flug
ich freue mich schon auf Dich ich freue
mich auch Geser
flacke hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf
Gefällt mir drückt und den Kanal
abonniert zeige ich euch meinen
lautesten Schrei für das menschliche
Gehör ist der zwar nicht wahrzunehmen
aber ich würde eure Hunde kurz
rausbringen okay
fertig